okay yeah it's a new function it's a
it's a quadratic right so it's a P of X
the parabola but a minus or something
it's an ax squared plus BX plus C you
know doing that with respect to X all
right now let's go ahead and let's just
eat your image okay cuz it's not that
hard to integrate I'll start with square
brackets ax squared turns into B X 32
and we just like the dance on the seat
okay and I've got my lower and upper
bounds okay now we can actually evaluate
this so we should expect some stuff to
get simple for us because of the nature
of these boundaries and also via that
the x squared that's going to be usable
slicing second so let's just evaluate
upper and lower bounds first you've got
8h - I just want you out to be a
negative yeah okay because I'm subbing
in minus H but that - is gonna appear a
couple times so be careful that you
don't miss it
this person was gonna be blindness H
huge this is gonna cancel out cos x
squared in this sea sorry H see H on the
end okay now you can see some stuff
cancels right number one this BH 3 2
minus 3 inch screen on - it goes right
and as second lady you've got - and then
develop negative and when I said it W
begin okay so here's why I now have
approximately equal to 2
a hu 3 + 2 CH by the right
okay now you look at that you're like
well okay that's it's it's kind of
simpler right but remember how how the
trapezoidal rule why was it useful to us
okay as opposed to integration sorry
this line here if you're gonna integrate
you need to know the competitors right
and we call that capital F okay but the
advantage of trapezoidal rule was you
didn't need to know what the pretty boys
it just needs to know the original
function and you can say well it's going
to be okay
has remembering what is on once let's
just do the basic forms of trapars over
the moon with just one trapezium half
star patron inch on two times one yeah
that's right no yeah so my first one
would be just okay right then you've got
double all these ones in the middle
however many you have okay and then
you've got your last one okay so the
reason why this is advantageous is
because I don't need to do a capital F
don't need to know the premium I just
need to know the original function now
here in this case I've got to be able to
get this it turns off just like your
trapezoid my original function by um in
this case it's P no F so how can I get
this in terms of this and specifically
this is function okay what are the
function donors like what are this
distance and this distance and this
distance
actually equal to it how would you work
for now yeah itself watch into what
wondering something
P yeah good I'm gonna take these values
I'm gonna sub it into P right ok so
let's just go ahead and work those out
so he's the first value right function
value rather P of minus ash what's going
to happen here the minus is going to
disappear so I'll get a H squared minus
v h+ it okay that's the middle function
name and the last function value how
long it's gonna be just like that with
one difference the plus okay so he's my
question just like we've used some parts
of roots right and they're like oh you
know you know what these two are can you
work out stuff like this okay
so your job was find a way to build this
out of these two they can you just did
some sort of manipulation so you can see
the connection so my question is if
these are the built not authority boss
these are my building blocks these are
my function days okay how do I put
together in such a way that and young
yeah have a look you got H huge and an
ancient right yeah okay basic user agent
no I don't have any eight cubes in my
building blocks okay so can anyone
suggest something that I can do which
would sort of get me closer
I can come in fact if you write because
I've got H here and age there right so
I'm going to take out a factor of H now
what about it I'm also going to take out
a factor of 1/3 because I don't like
fractions because I'm just like that so
what I get
I've got two ma H squared
yeah plus one because I've taken out
three this is gonna multiply so okay so
now I'm gonna itch cubes anymore this is
looking a little friendlier I've got a H
squares that's a promising okay but the
only way that I can get an edge screen
is by introducing one of these right pH
but I have no HS here so how do I get
rid of an inch
cuz those signs office yeah
so if I do Peter minus h plus P what am
I going to get well these two double
these two cancel these two that looks
promising
doesn't it pretty done actually if I
rewrite this a little bit we should be
what was their right to annotations
where head plus 2c that's what I do
that's my known but I've got six seek
here right so there's four hang your own
again but can you see where I hit before
from really from it's just gonna come
from the sky right okay so I am running
out of room when I throw this off but
you can keep referring to your room
okay I'm now going to get rid of all of
these and replace them with just the
function values that I know about okay
so it's going to be approximately equal
to H on three right times this thing
what was that
its base to functionality yeah and then
it only gives for C right must learn
where that comes from
okay because this is the difference
between the shoe rule I had for leech
okay now what is this this is um this
comes from yeah okay yes so I've got
everything in terms of piece here
right but my original question is about
effort at that log X 1 2 3 so I'm going
to translate everything back to is that
a piece I want from X okay now of course
I'm here in my diagram but you've got
yours right there right so what did P
minus of minus H what does P of ancient
lives here what do they correspond to
okay this is my area like it's
approximately equal to that H on 3 now
what's H H in our case it was reached at
that interval and we have this right
such that H what is that height it's
going to be the distance between them BT
minus a and then I divide by 2 right
because that's how I how many intervals
I divided into okay so this is my H on
the back P of minus H what was that that
was my first function value where did I
get it from
it's a failure rate for left value okay
P of H is my Ryan that the last one
right so that's gonna be okay
and then our formal walks off now what
was the middle value it was
f of a plus B close bracket okay yeah
three Internet's derivation do you need
to know it but the weeds no yes you did
no I mean GE what do you need to produce
it ice really doubt that okay but it's
in number one it's in the program number
two
it isn't tags mobility this is not
accessible like when we let limits in
calculus a lot come think a lot of those
things you have to worry about yet to
let it but this I think it's fitting
okay which is why I'm going to do okay
now just be one more thing to tidy up
where a fraction of a fraction keys so
that's suing that train together come up
six so here's my final I'm going to
rearrange this and get it right up
because this is first class middle so
I'll go first
middle and this four of those okay so
you believe that okay now remember I
told you how crazily similar scissors
ruler trapezoid rule are okay there's a
for instead of a two and well where'd
this come from this is h13
not angel - okay so the key to remember
which one is which is why are we
dividing by three it's cuz of what I did
over here there's actually the
integration thing that Davis is
refraction why do we divide trapezoidal
rule by two
why do we write divided by two
because it's the area which region and
no one can use the area which it means
it down isn't a third Hey or is it a
half no what does that because you guys
go check this as well right so that's
how I would remember indistinct so this
is what we call one more color this is
the basic form our citizens rule
so you may want to put another stop here
a little bit of tensions were you paying
whatever is down okay so that is the
basic form
all right now these one where else would
you please get up and move and stretch
because I'm going to show you the not
basically the whole time so get up and
move do something that was perfect
sorry you can eat but it doesn't